[Music]
baby
when i was a young gymnast i was exactly
like you i had a lot of love and passion
for the sport
but little simone she just flailed her
body
in the air and just thought it was
greatest thing of all time i needed to
work on my technique and fundamental
skills to improve
[Music]
whenever i was younger i was always the
type of gymnast
to be like lollygagging around and i'm
like oh my god it's my turn
let's go i learned discipline inside the
gym
in this master class i want to show you
the fundamentals
from basics to advanced skills
i will also demonstrate more advanced
and elite skills
initiate your twist with your feet then
hips then shoulders no matter what skill
you execute off the table
it's really important to block first
rise and then twist
[Music]
honestly right there i was thinking
don't screw up i'm literally terrified
right now
i'm already struggling and you can see
i'm rushing my hands weren't completely
placed on the bars
you always have to go through and finish
whatever performance you're doing
if you're not nervous once you go out to
compete then something's wrong
keep working hard in the gym communicate
what you want from your coaches
and always remember these things don't
happen overnight it takes a lot of work
to get to where we are
but with practice and confidence you can
accomplish your dreams too
i'm simone biles and this is my master
[Music]
class
you